thank you ryan here to accept
the 2021 eastern conference championship
trophy
is the general manager of the milwaukee
bucks john
force congratulations on winning the
eastern conference it's now time to pick
up
your trophy congratulations to the 2021
eastern conference champions
the milwaukee bucks
john while they celebrate this team was
built
to win a championship you're here now
going to the finals what has this
journey been like
no steph i can't quite hear you but i'm
just gonna say thank you to atlanta
hawks for a great series
obviously to these players uh peter
fagan our team president our owners mark
west jamie and mike
uh and obviously coach boonholzer you
know what an incredible accomplishment
for this team and just really excited
for the guys go bucs thank you john
congratulations again let's hear from
coach budenholzer
coach congratulations i know you said
you love every team that you've coached
but this team is taking you to the
finals
why is this team special well first just
congratulations to atlanta coach
mcmillan his players hell of a season
amazing yeah it's sweet these guys have
put the work in all year they deserve to
go to the finals
i couldn't be more proud of them i love
coaching them and we got more work to do
drew stay right up here drew come on
drew let's hear from you
we've talked quite a bit your coach
addressed it about your play
being aggressive you led the way in this
game early
what's it like to hold that in your arms
man a feeling that i've never felt
before
as a little kid everybody here wanted
one to be a part of this
uh just a chance to go to the finals is
amazing so
super blessed uh everybody i'm so proud
of y'all bro
hey let's get one of phoenix baby
thank you drew chris middleton
from olympian to olympian now you're
headed you're headed to the finals chris
third quarter you took over what allowed
you to do that
my teammates and my coaches uh they told
me to keep being aggressive
one of the coaches told us somebody
passes to the rim set of the turnovers
so
just shoot be confident uh and just try
to play the right way
you've worked hard to get to this point
now you're headed to the nba finals with
this group of guys
what does that mean i love it each one
of these guys they work every single day
everybody stays ready everybody stays
locked in we all pay for each other
that's all you can ask for
thank you chris again congratulations to
the 2021 eastern conference
champions
apparently there's quite a contingent
here from
milwaukee never easy accepting the
trophy
at a presentation on the opponent's
court well that's awesome
and you can hear the genuine rewards
you know come from coach budd and from
holiday and middleton
two guys that really put this team on
their back when
their two-time mvp went down uh giannis
entertacumpo
and uh now what a finals we have set up
for us
between phoenix and milwaukee this is
gonna be fun to watch
now the last time the bucks advanced to
the nba finals 1974 against the boston
celtics
kareem abdul-jabbar then lou alcindor
would hit the game-winning hook
in game six as the hook shot by kareem
forcing
a game seven in game seven the celtics
went on to defeat
the bucks 102 87 and win the nba
championship john hablachick went out to
be the
finals bucks did wood in
1971 uh led by
louis cinder and oscar robertson as you
see the dia district this celebration
may go on
quite some time they're going to meet
them at the airport just like we saw
that
scene in the valley when phoenix came
home after
beating the clippers